[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Das Fruchteis hat euch ja neulich schon ziemlich gut gefallen.
Heute gibt es noch eine zweite Variante,
ein Schokoladeneis.
Auch blitzschnell gemacht ohne Eismaschine
mit nur wenigen Zutaten,
vegan, glutenfrei,
ohne Zucker.
Also ich glaube, mehr braucht man
zu diesem Eis gar nicht sagen.
Dafür nehme ich 200 Gramm Avocados,
300 Gramm reife Bananen,
50 Gramm Kakaopulver ohne Zucker natürlich,
100 Gramm Kokosmilch oder eine andere Milch.
Hier habe ich etwas Vanilleextrakt
und Schokoladenstreusel.
Bei der Avocado wirklich darauf achten,
dass sie schön reif ist.
Also ich gucke dann auch immer, dass sie weich ist.
Und hier oben könnt ihr diesen Knopf da mal wegnehmen.
Und dann ist sie da drinnen schön grün.
Wenn sie braun ist, ist sie praktisch
schon ein bisschen zu reif,
überreif.
Da würde ich dann die Finger weglassen.
Aber ansonsten einfach
wirklich schöne weiche Avocado nehmen.
Die hätten jetzt noch ein bisschen weicher sein dürfen.
Aber es ist okay.
Bei den Bananen auch gerne darauf achten,
dass sie sehr reif sind.
Und da habe ich es jetzt sogar schon gemacht,
ich habe sie vorbereitet
und zwar einfach geschält und eingefroren.
So habe ich schon mal eine kalte Banane.
Und im Prinzip nehmt ihr jetzt einfach eure Schüssel,
wiegt praktisch die Bananen ab,
also die 300 Gramm.
Die friere ich wieder ein
und packe sie dann auch in eine Schüssel
für das nächste Mal
oder für Smoothies zum Beispiel.
Dann habe ich immer Bananen auf Vorrat
wie einfach tiefgefrorene Früchte.
Es sind einfach exakt 300,0.
Will ich jetzt mal nur
nur betonen.
Nicht?
Oh! Es ist gesprungen!
Das war der Windstoß!
Und mit reifen Bananen meine ich auch wirklich superreif.
Also die dürfen schon so aussehen.
Die werden praktisch geschält, geschnitten, eingefroren.
Und dann habt ihr die wirklich immer schön auf Vorrat.
Jetzt kann ich hier noch die Avocado dazu abwiegen,
also wirklich immer schön das geschälte Gewicht.
Dann habt ihr auch jedes Mal das Eis
in der gleichen Qualität
und eben mit dem gleichen Geschmack.
Ach, die Ela wollte auch mithelfen.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ela, Schatz, wenn du Hände wäschst,
kannst du mithelfen.
>> ELA: Okay.
Wow!
So ein einfaches Eis und ich habe gleich drei Helferinnen!
>> SAMIRA: Warum kommt da Avocado rein?
>> SALLY: Für die Cremigkeit.
Genau, die Avocado.
Das ist eine gute Frage, Samira.
Die Avocado kommt rein für die Cremigkeit,
damit das Eis...
>> SAMIRA: Schmeckt man das dann auch raus?
>> SALLY: Das schmeckt man nicht raus.
Das ist praktisch der Ersatz für Eier
und für Sahne,
was man eben normalerweise in Ei hat.
Und daher nehmen wir jetzt hier eben die Avocado.
Gut.
Jetzt darf die Ela ein bisschen helfen,
weil ihr ja schon beim Fruchteis geholfen habt.
Komm mal rüber, Ela, mit deinem Hocker.
Vorsicht, Samira.
>> ELA: Und kommt da Schokolade drauf?
>> SALLY: Ja, wir machen Schokostreusel rein.
>> SAMIRA: Und Schokostreusel drauf.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe es jetzt hier so gemacht,
dass ich den Multizerkleinerer, also meinen Mixer,
einfach auch eingefroren habe.
Dann ist der auch schon mal schön kalt.
Komm, Spatz! Sonst tauen die Bananen wieder auf.
Komm!
Ich ziehe das mal ganz kurz weiter rüber.
Denn sonst kommst du ja gar nicht dran.
>> ELA: Ich habe ein paar Schokostreusel genascht.
>> SAMIRA: Reicht das schon?
>> SALLY: Ich gebe das jetzt hier oben kurz rein,
weil, Ela, für dich ist das, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu schwer.
Und du darfst jetzt aber
Vanilleextrakt dazu geben.
Übertreib es nicht!
Stopp!
Puh! Puh!
Ela, man muss immer wirklich nur wenig nehmen!
Nur einen Teelöffel oder sogar noch weniger.
Das teuerste Eis meines Lebens!
>> ELA: Oder null wenig?
>> SALLY: Null?
Nee, null nicht.
Aber so 0,5.
Bitte schön.
Kakaopulver,
also Backkakao.
Zack!
>> ELA: Puh!
>> SALLY: Kokosmilch.
>> ELA: Ich mache das!
>> SALLY: Und, wenn ihr sagt, ihr mögt
den Geschmack von Kokosmilch nicht,
könnt ihr natürlich auch normale Milch nehmen
oder etwas Crème fraîche
oder Sahne.
Aber ihr seht, auch bei diesem Rezept
kommt praktisch kein Industriezucker mit rein,
sondern wir nutzen die Banane als Süßungskraft.
>> ELA: Oder, wenn ihr nicht Avocado mögt,
dann macht ihr keine Avocado rein.
>> SALLY: Zum Beispiel.
>> ELA: Aber zum Beispiel Ananas könnt ihr reinmachen.
>> SALLY: Ela macht einfach direkt ein neues Rezept.
Und jetzt mixen!
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Das ist dein Löffel.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Und das sind unsere Löffel.
>> SALLY: Aha!
Wo bleibt denn da die Fairness?!
Okay.
Das ist okay.
Ich komme damit klar.
>> ELA: Nein, ich möchte den kleinen Löffel!
Dann kann ich besser essen.
>> SAMIRA: Ach so!
Dann kriegst du aber nicht so viel davon.
>> ELA: Na gut.
>> SALLY: Also wir probieren jetzt praktisch mal.
>> ELA: Okay, dann nehme ich einen großen Löffel.
>> SALLY: Wartet. Lasst mich mal kurz vortesten.
Denn
ich erhöhe die Bananenmenge.
Denn den Kindern wird es
zu wenig süß sein.
Ich nehme noch ein bisschen mehr Banane, okay?
Denn ich habe ziemlich viel Kakao rein.
Das schmeckt jetzt gerade noch ein bisschen herb.
Das schmeckt ihr einfach ab.
Aber ich schreibe euch gleich die geänderte Menge eben
in den Blog.
Vor allem ist es bei Eis so,
je...
Also, wenn es...
Ihr müsst so probieren und es muss süßer schmecken.
Weil, wenn es gefroren ist, verliert sich die Süße.
Noch ein bisschen mehr Banane, nicht?
Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Aber es riecht eigentlich ganz gut.
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr mal probieren, Mädels?
Okay.
Und dann
probiert ihr einfach gleich noch mal nach dem Einfrieren, ja?
Ist egal wo.
Hier.
Gib das der Greta. Das war deiner.
Der war aber auch sauber.
Und es kommen ja noch die Schokostückchen rein.
Also noch mal ein bisschen Banane.
Ich mache mal 200,
noch mal 200 Gramm drauf.
Zack!
>> ELA: Ist das jetzt...
Härtet das jetzt?
>> SALLY: Nee, das härtet gleich im Gefrierfach.
>> ELA: Wuh!
>> SALLY: Okay, Mädels.
>> ELA: Ich höre jetzt auf zu naschen.
>> SALLY: Hörst du jetzt auf zu naschen, ja?
>> ELA: Ich esse nur noch die.
Oder die.
>> SALLY: So finde ich es gut.
Probier mal, Greta.
>> ELA: Aber die beiden sind
hier auf den Tisch gefallen.
>> SALLY: Probier mal, Ela.
Und ich glaube, wenn das gleich einfriert...
>> SAMIRA: Mit den Schokostreuseln!
>> SALLY: Mit den Schokostreuseln.
>> SAMIRA: Schmeckt gut!
>> ELA: Perfekt!
>> SALLY: Also hier jetzt kurz abkratzen.
>> SAMIRA: Kann ich kurz noch mal ein bisschen haben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Bitte.
>> SALLY: Moment. Ich mache kurz das Messer sauber.
Aber mit Schokostreuseln probieren, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Ja. Deswegen haben wir ja welche in der Hand.
>> SALLY: Ihr seid vielleicht Naschkatzen!
>> SAMIRA: Warum machst du das da hinten hin?
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Ich will nur das Messer rausmachen.
>> ELA: Kann ich meinen Löffel haben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
So.
Huch!
So Feinschmecker!
Die Kinder sind Feinschmecker.
Ich rühre jetzt hier auch noch die Schokostreusel ein.
Und dann friere ich es ein für etwa zwei Stunden
und rühre einfach ab und zu durch.
Das ist jetzt praktisch der Part,
wo ihr die Eismaschine ersetzt
und praktisch selber mal alle 30 Minuten rühren müsst,
damit das Eis schön cremig wird.
Aber wir nehmen eine flache Schale.
Dann gefriert es auch schneller.
[Musik]
So ein Kind ist okay.
Zwei Kinder auch.
Bei drei Kindern ist es schon eine
Geduldsprobe.
Aber bleibt chillig, bleibt locker!
Sie danken es euch.
Hauptsache, sie haben eine Beschäftigung
und gleich ein leckeres Eis
ohne Zusatzzucker.
Die Kinder sind glücklich.
Dann ist die Mama auch glücklich.
[Musik]
Seid ihr bereit für Schokoladeneis?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> GRETA: Ja.
>> ELA: Ja, wir sind es!
>> SALLY: Also es ist noch nicht ganz gefroren.
Aber ich finde das jetzt gar nicht so schlimm.
Dann ist es auch nicht so kalt.
Da machen wir so.
>> ELA: Ist das Cookie Dough?
>> SALLY: Nein, das ist Eis.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ta-daa!
Das ist jetzt noch so Softeis.
Also ich hatte es auch nur eine Stunde im Gefrierfach.
>> ELA: Videoeis.
>> SALLY: So. Wer am stillsten ist,
bekommt das Eis zuerst.
Ruhige Kinder, brave Kinder,
gedulige Kinder.
Wer ist noch ein ruhiges Kind?
Wer möchte ein Schokoeis?
>> ELA: Ich!
>> SALLY: Bist du ein ruhiges Kind?
Sie lügt halt auch nicht.
Kommt, probiert euer Eis!
>> ELA: Ich mache noch Streusel...
>> SALLY: Nee, keine Streusel!
Da sind Streusel drin,
im Eis drin.
>> ELA: Hier?
>> SALLY: Ja, schleck es mal ab und probiere es mal.
Hm.
>> ELA: Hä?
Ich spüre keine Streusel.
>> SALLY: Banane-Schokolade, nicht?
Was meint ihr?
>> SAMIRA: Gut.
>> GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es auch gut.
Also für mich passt die Süße perfekt.
Ich denke, für die Kinder auch.
Sie sind halt natürlich süßeres Eis gewohnt.
Aber ich wollte jetzt auch einfach keinen Zucker dazu geben
oder noch mal ein anderes Süßungsmittel.
Von daher passt es perfekt!
Ihr könnt euch noch ein paar Streusel drauf machen.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen,
friere mein Eis wieder ein.
Dann kann Murat auch noch was essen
und das restliche Team hier.
Und dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Und schreibt mir gerne, wenn ihr weitere
solche schnellen Rezepte und einfachen Rezepte sehen wollt.
Okay?
Bis bald!
Ja, heute gibt es eine Miniportion Eis.
Das reicht, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Komm, Ela, wir gehen raus!
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Können wir mal zu Sturmwaffel?
>> SALLY: Zum Sturmwaffel willst du gehen?
Ja, dann warte mal.
>> ELA: Gehen wir Sturmwaffel besuchen?
Aber erst, wenn Corona vorbei ist.
>> SALLY: Jetzt frag mal in die Kamera.
Der hört dich.
Sag mal Sturmi.
>> ELA: Mama?
Können wir?
Können wir
zu Sturmwaffel?
Aber nur, wenn Corona vorbei ist.
Wegen Corona darf man ja zu niemandem gehen.
Aber bei Luisa war ich einmal so.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, dann frag mal in die Kamera.
Sag mal: "Hey Sturmwaffel, dürfen wir dich besuchen?"
Ich glaube, der hört dich dann,
wenn du in die Kamera sprichst.
Hier, guck beim Josh rein.
>> ELA: Sturmwaffel?
Dürfen wir mal zu dir nach Hause?
Aber erst, wenn Corona vorbei ist.
>> SAMIRA: Ich auch!
Hallo!
>> SALLY: Greta auch?
>> GRETA: Ja.
[Musik]